Our guest today is uh Robert Spencer,
one of the world's leading experts on uh
Islamic ideology, jihadist uh movements,
and middlean history. He's the author of
more than two dozen books, including the
Palestinian delusion, the catastrophic
history of the Middle East peace
process, and he's actually our first
interview on our Stand Tall Israel
channel. And is a pleasure and an honor
to to have you. Thank you for being here
with us, Mr. Spencer. I want this to be
an eye-opening conversation today for
those people that woke up on October 7th
basically and didn't know what's going
on with this conflict. Why is there
always fighting in this in this little
piece of land? Give us, you know, the
historical and all the misconceptions
that might be concerning this land and
uh we'll take it from there.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, October 7th was just
one of the more recent episodes in an
ongoing jihad that started in earnest
really in the early part of the 20th
century when there were when there was
largecale Jewish immigration into
Palestine. Now even when I say that it's
susceptible to tremendous
misunderstanding because people then say
people who are uninformed historically
say you see there was Palestine and then
the Jews showed up and that caused all
the trouble. Actually what this was was
the ancestral homeland of the Jews. Some
of whom the Yeshu had lived there
throughout history. And then there was
because of the Zionist movement an
influx of those who had been in exile
for many centuries back to this
ancestral homeland. Palestine was the
name of the region that the Romans had
given to Judea and Samaria in the year
134 CE. Now they renamed Judea Palestine
because they were exiling the Jews from
that ancestral homeland after the
Barovba revolt because they wanted to
insult the Jews and sever their obvious
connection to this land. They wanted to
aace the name of it that that was land
of the Jews Judea and call it something
else. What else to call it? They went to
the Bible, found the Philistines who
were the which was the name of the
ancient enemy of the Israelites
according to the scriptures and
consequently they named the place after
them. Now there are today Palestinian
Arab spokesman who claim well this is
because we are the Philistines but there
is actually no historical continuity.
The Philistines had long before the
Romans called the place Palestine had
died out and there were no Philistines.
They only chose this name to insult the
Jews. Anyway, 20th century the Jews are
returning in large numbers starting in
the late 19th century of course and the
Arab Muslims are enraged. It is an
there's so many myths and lies about
this issue and one of them is that the
the Arabs it welcomed in the Jewish
immigrants which is completely
ridiculous. The Arab Muslims were
enraged at the Zionist movement because
they believed that the land belonged to
them. Why did the land belong to them?
Because the Quran and Islamic tradition
and law teach that any land that
belonged to the Muslims at any point in
history belongs to the Muslims forever.
And if there is any land, which has
actually only rarely happened, that any
land ceases to be ruled by Muslims after
it had been, then it is the
responsibility before Allah of those
Muslims to wage war to get that land
back. As the Quran says twice, drive
them out from where they drove you out.
And so a lot of people uh think that
that when people quote it nowadays
refers to the so-called Nakba of 1948
when the Israelis allegedly expelled the
Palestinians from the land which isn't
actually the case either but actually
when Muslims invoke this passage from
the Quran they are doing so on the basis
of the fact that the Arab invaders
starting in the 7th century and then the
Turks after them. The Ottomans ruled the
land by Islamic law and consequently the
Muslims have the responsibility to wage
jihad to drive them out. Drive them out
from where they drove you out. When the
state of Israel was founded, the five
Arab states surrounding it immediately
declared war. And that was when actually
the Arab higher committee told the Arab
Muslims of the area to leave because
they thought they were going to destroy
the Jewish state in a matter of weeks
and they wanted to get them out of the
line of fire. Instead, they lost the war
and this is the beginning of the idea
that there is this massive population of
Palestinian refugees. But I know I'm
going on a bit, but there's so much to
this. I could just actually just talk
for for an hour here, but uh I'll I'll
conclude for the moment with this that
in all of this that I've just roughly
outlined, the Romans activity in the
second century, the beginning of the
Zionist movement, the establishment of
the state of Israel. Now, nowhere were
there actually any Palestinians. And
throughout history, you can look at
histories of the region and people
accounts of travelers throughout the
region and you don't find any mention of
Palestinians. The Palestinians never
existed as a distinct people. the people
who were there besides the Jews who had
always lived there and some Christians
who had lived there throughout history
as well from the founding of
Christianity there were also some Arab
Muslims and they were indistinguishable
ethnically, linguistically, culturally
and religiously from the Arabs of Syria,
Jordan, Lebanon and so on. The idea of
the Palestinians was actually invented
in the 1960s as a rhetorical weapon to
use against the state of Israel by
claiming that these are the real
indigenous people of the land who have
the prior rights of the land over that
of the Israelis and those who care about
the oppressed and brown people and and
indigenous people and all that, they
have to support the Palestinians and
that's where we are. But the whole thing
is actually the most successful
propaganda initiative in the history of
the world and the Palestinians do not
actually exist.
>> Okay. So from what you're saying, this
started way before 1948. Could you speak
a little bit about the anti-Jewish riots
and and violence that there was in
Israel before 1948, Kevron massacre and
and and things like that. Yeah, this is
very important because many of them were
led and incited by Hajim Husini, the
Grand Mui of Jerusalem. And he of course
is notorious for the famous photograph
of him with Hitler, but it was much more
than just a photo op. Al Husini actually
lived in Berlin from 1941 to 45. He
collaborated closely with the National
Socialists. He actually was friends with
Hitler and Iman. He made broadcasts in
Arabic to the Arabic speaking countries
calling upon them to ally with the
Germans. He raised up an SS, a Muslim SS
division out of Bosnian Muslims. And it
also seems as if he may have given the
Nazis the idea for the gas chambers that
were used in the Holocaust because he
saw primitive gas chambers being used by
the Turks against the Armenians in the
Armenian genocide. He was a soldier in
the Ottoman army at that time. And it's
noteworthy that Hitler in speaking about
eradicating the Jews made an an a direct
analogy with the Armenians and said even
today who remembers the Armenians and
you got to wonder why do you remember
the Armenians Adolf? Was somebody
talking to you about them maybe? But
even aside from that, even aside from
speculation on that, we know that he
agitated with the Nazis to not allow
Jews to escape from Europe and go to
Palestine. And he told them, you got to
figure out another solution here. That's
when the gas chambers started to be
constructed. Now long before this in the
early 20s he was working with the
British who were occupying the territory
under the mandate for Palestine which
was given by the League of Nations to
the British for the purpose of
establishing a Jewish national home
which is Israel. So the British although
they were committed to establishing a
Jewish national home were actually quite
opposed to the idea in practice. There
were some who were for it, but more
often than not, British officials wanted
to work with the Arabs. The Arabs had
helped them against the Ottomans during
World War I. It's the whole Lawrence of
Arabia business. Colonel Te Lawrence was
the British official who worked with the
Arabs to agitate and get them to fight
the Ottomans, which helped the British
because the Ottomans were on the German
side. So after the war they felt this
tremendous gratitude to the Arabs and
they thought of the Zionist Jewish Jews
Jewish settlers as an irritant as an
afterthought. So they worked in various
ways to try to discourage the Zionist
settlement. And one of the most evil of
these ways was they actually encouraged
Hajim al- Husseini to massacre Jews in
the area. And they told him that if he
did so they would not pro far far be it
would they prosecute him. That was not
on anybody's mind they would reward him.
And so he did carry out this a series of
massacres in Jerusalem as well as in
Hebrron and elsewhere. And the British
didn't do anything but issue white
papers saying we got to restrict Jewish
settlement here. And so he went from
that to Germany. And after the war, even
though he could easily have been
prosecuted at Nuremberg for war crimes,
he was allowed to escape to Egypt where
he was instrumental in formulating the
new Arab resistance or jihad really
against the state of Israel. And of
course, he is also remembered today as
the uncle of Yaser Arafat. It's
interesting to to hear about this Nazi
alliance with this early jihad ideology.
You would think that they didn't have
much in common, but their Jew hatred,
right? I mean, was there is that what
united them or was it something else?
>> Well, there was a little bit more. That
was certainly the main reason. And if
you look at the text, I've got it in
I've got the some extensive quotes in
the Palestinian delusion text of Al
Husini's speeches in Arabic to the Arab
Muslims during World War II. He's
leaning heavily on Quranic passages that
are attacking the Jews. And so he's
saying, "We all hate Jews together. Ally
with the Germans who are killing."
But there was a little bit more because
Hitler actually is quoted as saying that
it's a shame that Charles Martell
stopped the Muslims in their advance
into France at tour in the year 732
which was the high water mark of the
Islamic advance into Western Europe
until today of course. and he said it is
a shame, it was a great misfortune for
the German people that the Muslims
didn't advance and conquer Germany
because a German population that was
Muslim would have been invincible. He
said Christianity with its meekness and
flabiness is not suited to the marshall
spirit of the German people in the way
that Islam is and that Islam would have
been a much better religion for them. Is
it possible to speak a little bit about
the founding of the Muslim Brotherhood
and and where that went from there?
>> Yeah, the Muslim Brotherhood is an
international organization that was
founded in 1928 in order to restore the
caliphate. The caliphate is the only
political entity to which Muslims should
give their allegiance according to
Islamic law. Now of course this is
problematic in practice because today
there is no caliphate. But according to
the theory in Islamic law there is a
successor a caiff kilafa is successor
and the caiff is the successor of
Muhammad as the military political and
spiritual leader of all the Muslims
worldwide. There have been great
caliphates in history the Umiads the
Abbassads the Ottomans and so on but
none of them actually ruled all the
Muslims in the world. But that is the
theory that this is the only legitimate
government to which Muslims owe
allegiance. It's a very important aspect
of Islamic theology that the Muslims be
a political entity and also a unified
single political entity. So in 1924
an extraordinary thing happened. The
founder of modern Turkey Mustafa Kamal
Adaturk who was also very evil in his
own way but that's that's a different
story. He actually was unique in the
entire history of Islam in blaming Islam
for the Ottomans lost in World War I.
And he said the West is is Christian or
secular and they won and we need to
establish a western style secular
republic in the way that the West has
and then and get rid of Islam which he
called the theology of an immoral bedin.
And so he established secular Turkey
which still exists although it's much
less secular than it was when he started
it and it's not going to be secular at
all for much longer. But in any case he
established it and in 1924 he abolished
the caliphate.
The the last caiffs were the sultanss of
the Ottoman Empire. And so first he of
course the Ottoman Empire had dissolved
but he kept the caiff on because he was
still the religious leader of the
Muslims but in 1920 got rid of that as
well. So the Muslim Brotherhood four
years later is designed to restore the
caliphate to restore this important
unity political unity of the Muslim
world and they blame a lot of the
troubles of the Islamic world on the
fact that it is disunited and under the
thr of the western democracies. So the
Muslim Brotherhood establishes itself
all over the world. Even today it's one
of it's pretty much the largest Muslim
organization. I'd be surprised if there
were another that were larger. Every
major Muslim group in the United States
is linked to the Muslim Brotherhood.
Hamas calls itself the Muslim
Brotherhood for Palestine. And the whole
idea is to wage jihad all around the
world, whether by violent or stealthy
means. In the United States, they're not
blowing stuff up. They're doing it by
stealthy means, infiltration, and
influence operations and so on. And the
whole idea is ultimately to establish a
caliphate and Israel has to be destroyed
of course as part of that because in the
first place it's on Muslim land as I
explained before and also it's a
particular insult to Islam because it is
ruled by Jews and the Jews according to
the Quran are the worst enemies of the
Muslims and so their foremost opponents
have established a state on land that
belong belongs to Islam. The Brotherhood
and its various offshoots think that's a
terrible insult. This is why in the
Hamas charter, it actually says Israel
will arise and remain until Islam
obliterates it. And that's a quote from
Hassan Abana, the founder of the Muslim
Brotherhood. I think that's been
sufficiently appreciated particularly in
Washington, but also in Jerusalem and
elsewhere that it's not they don't say
the Palestinians until the Palestinians
obliterate it or until the Arabs
obliterate it. They say until Islam
obliterates it. And you've got Iran,
you've got the Palestinian Authority,
you've got Hisba, you've got Hamas, you
got all of them. Whenever they speak
about this conflict in general, they
speak about Islam. And yet in every
communicate from every American
president, they never mention Islam at
all. And it seems to me you're you guys
are missing what they're telling us
about what this conflict is all about.
And that is a recipe for making sure
that your solutions will never work as
they never have.
>> Could you speak a little bit more about
why Islam hates Judaism so much and what
is what is the the root over there?
Quran says that it is a new revelation
that is the confirmation of what is in
the Torah and the gospel and that if the
Jews and the Christians look in their
books they will find that Islam is true.
Now of course Jews and Christians have
looked in their books and they don't
find Islam is true. And this is the
famous Islamic dilemma that is getting a
lot of publicity lately that the Quran
tells Jews and Christians to consult
their own books to determine if Islam is
true, but when they do, they don't find
that it's true. And so, Muslims charge
that the Jews and Christians have
actually dared to tamper with their own
holy books. And so, not only are the
Jews the worst enemies of the Muslims,
but they're enemies of God as well,
because they have taken his revelations
and dared to alter them to suit
themselves. Now, Islam does not just
make theological statements like that
and leave them. Islam is a political
religion as well as I mean, it's
political as well as religious. So when
you say the Jews are renegades who have
rejected Allah, rejected his true
prophet, rejected the latest holy book
and are actually tampering with their
holy book and are the enemies of the
Muslims and of Allah. Well then you come
up against a very important passage of
the Quran that is also very frequently
overlooked and that is chapter 9 14 and
15 which says fight them and Allah will
punish them by your hands. Allah will
punish them by your hands. That is you
are the executives of the divine
punishment. The Muslims are the ones who
bring the wrath of Allah to the to the
disbelievers. And so it's not just that
the Jews are enemies of Allah and the
Muslims who have rejected the true
prophet and tampered with their
scriptures. It is also that the Muslims
have the responsibility to fight them so
that Allah can punish them. And this is
why, for example, the Islamic Republic
of Iran hates Israel. Iran doesn't have
a border with Israel. Iran doesn't have
competing economic interests with
Israel. There's no reason for those two
countries to be enemies except Islam.
That the Quran says all these things
about the Jews. And there's much more. I
could go on for hours also about the Jew
hatred that is in the Quran and Sunnah.
But it's because of that that Iran hates
Israel. And only because of that. speak
about a little bit about the birth of
Hamas and the the history of of Hamas
and um you know throughout the decades.
>> Well, to understand the birth of Hamas,
you have to understand in the first
place that when Yaser Arafat invented
the Palestinians in 1964, he did so in
collaboration with the KGB. Yaser
Arafat, you may recall, always wore
military fatings or often wore military
fatigues.
He was, in other words, he was not
wearing the garb of a sheh. He was not
dressed as a Muslim leader. He was the
leader of an insurgent movement of
militants that were allied with the
communists if they weren't communists
themselves. Of course, the popular front
for the liberation of Palestine is
openly Marxist, but Arafat was very much
aligned with all of that when he started
out in the 60s. You have the KGB and
Arafat inventing the Palestinians and
casting them as a movement of the
oppressed colonized oppressed brown
people against the white colonialist
oppressors, the Israelis. And so it's
all Marxist rhetoric about oppressor
versus oppressed. And at that time they
did not speak a great deal about Islam.
Now, Islam was always in the background
because they were all Muslims. And the
only reason why they wouldn't have have
an agreement, an ordinary agreement such
as people have had throughout history in
thousands of different contexts. You
have a disagreement, you compromise,
every each side compromises a little
bit, and you take what you can get and
that's it. But in this case, there's
never any agreement that ever works
because Islam is maximalist. It demands
the whole thing. Drive them out from
where they drove you out. Not just drive
them out of part of it and leave them
the rest in a two-state solution or
something like that. Drive them out. All
of it. So, they're not talking about
Islam, but Islam is in the background.
They're talking about the oppressed,
Marxism, fighting against the occupier,
the oppressor, and all that. And of
course, that's still very much part of
the rhetoric and why the left has fallen
for this so hard. But there was always a
faction among the Palestinian Arabs that
considered that illegitimate and wanted
to talk more freely and openly about the
fact that this was an Islamic conflict.
And so they started Hamas in 1987 as a
competitor to the Palestinians to I'm
sorry to the PLO, the Palestinian
Liberation Organization that later
became the Palestinian Authority in the
'90s because they thought that these
people weren't sufficiently Islamic. And
so they are open about their desire to
destroy all of Israel. They don't want
to sit down and talk and negotiate and
divide up the land. They want to destroy
Israel totally because that's the
Islamic imperative. Now the PLO and the
PA, they actually hold to all this too.
But because it had been so muted in
their rhetoric and because they were
willing to sit down and negotiate and
use the negotiations, mind you, step by
step to work toward destroying Israel,
they thought that it would be better
these the the people who founded Hamas
to create a more explicitly Islamic
movement. So could you speak a little
bit about, you know, the Oslo Accords,
how every peace deal failed, Arafat kind
of uh fooling the West into thinking
that he actually wanted peace and uh so
on and so forth.
>> Yeah. Well, you know, Oslo is of course
one of a string of failed accords that
goes back to Camp David and continues.
Camp David is still enforced to some
degree, but it was terrible from the
beginning that Israel was made to
withdraw from land it had legitimately
won in a defensive war. And it was a
rule of warfare throughout history that
if you are attacked and you win against
an aggressor, you can seize territory to
protect yourself against further attacks
from that aggressor. Everybody took that
for granted. That's why Germany is so
much smaller now than it was before
World War II. But when it comes to
Israel, it doesn't apply. So, Israel was
made to withdraw from Sinai and so on.
And it was only in exchange for promises
that have turned out to be to a
tremendous degree empty. But in any
case, the reasons why these negotiations
always fail is exactly what I've been
explaining that jihad is is is not
negotiable. There is no way that a pious
believing Muslim is going to say, "I
will stop trying to destroy Israel
because we made this agreement." Because
destroying Israel, as far as he's
concerned, is serving a law. And just as
a Jew or Christian is not going to say,
"Well, let's sit down. I'll negotiate
away the sixth commandment, if you make
a good deal, will we'll just scratch
that one out." It's not negotiable. You
always have it there. And it's the same
thing with the drive them out from where
they drove you out. They can't erase it
from the Quran. So, Arafat would lie.
Now, he would lie because lying is
allowed in these kinds of contexts. In
the first place, Muhammad said war is
deceit. War is deceit. And he allowed
for lying between a husband and a wife.
The husband could lie to the wife all he
wants. And in wartime, and of course,
most importantly, in wartime, you can
make your enemies think you're on their
side. This is the wording of Molana
Malduni who was a very famous Pakistani
politician and Islamic scholar in the
20th century and in explaining the Quran
where it says don't take friends take
infidels as your friends and protectors
in preference to believers whoever does
that has nothing to do with the law
unless you're doing it to guard
yourselves against them that's chapter 3
28 m duty explained that by saying this
means that we can pretend to be on the
side of our enemies if it's tactically
necessary. So that's what he did at
Oslo. He agreed to all these things. He
went home. People were angry and he
said, "Don't worry about it. It's Huda."
What's Huda? This is a treaty that
Muhammad concluded according to Islamic
tradition in the year 628. In the year
628, he was fighting the Meccans who
were the pagan Arabs. He was from Mecca,
but they had rejected his claim to be a
prophet. and he asked them to conclude
an agreement. They were the stronger
party and they agreed to conclude this
agreement with him whereby they would
not fight for 10 years. He was only
using it to have a respit from the
fighting so that he could gather his
forces and in augment his forces so that
he could defeat them later. So long
before the 10 years were up, he broke
the treaty and
the mechans were overed. They saw that
he was much more powerful and they
surrendered without a fight. But that is
the paradigm for all Islamic treatym. If
you are losing, you ask your enemy for a
truce. The truce can last for as long as
10 years. And you use that time to
gather strength to fight again more
effectively. So Arafat went home and he
told the people in Arabic, "This is the
treaty of Huda." He meant we're just
biting our time and gathering strength.
This is not a real truce like we're
making peace and gonna live side by side
in peace with Israel. And meanwhile,
Bill Clinton, he didn't know any of this
and he just thought, well, I've just
made peace. I'm I'm going to get me
Nobel Prize. And he thought that he was
going to actually make bring this whole
conflict to an end. But I don't mean to
pick on Bill. It wasn't he wasn't any
dumber about this than any other
American president. Every last one of
them has thought they're going to solve
this problem. and they think that
they're going to do so because they
don't understand Islam and they don't
understand it when Arafat says something
like this is who I bea and they don't
care to be told. So they keep making the
same mistakes again and again and again.
>> You mentioned the presidents. So what's
currently happening right now with you
know Donald Trump trying to make you
know saying there's peace. What do you
what do you have to say about that?
>> The same thing. He wants a Nobel Prize,
too. And maybe he'll get one, but it's
just as it'd be just as hollow as the
one they gave to Jimmy Carter and, you
know, all the rest of it and Arafat for
that matter. The the president is making
exactly the same mistake that has been
made by all the other presidents and
that is thinking that this is a conflict
that the opponents are thinking of in
Western terms. In the West, you have a
war for a while and one side is winning
and the other side surrenders and signs
a paper saying it's all done. That's not
what happens in jihad. In jihad, they
only sign a paper, like I said, to get
10 years to gather their strength to
fight again. There is no doubt
whatsoever, excuse me, no doubt
whatsoever that this treat that Trump
has touted so wholeheartedly is going to
fail and Trump is going to attack it.
Hamas is going to attack Israel again
and Israeli civilians are going to get
killed again. And he stopped them from
eradicating Hamas, which also would not
have ended the jihad, but would have set
it back maybe decades. and he stopped
them because he thought he's a dealmaker
and we're going to sign this deal and
it's going to be the best deal you ever
saw and it's just going to be the same
failure we have seen again and again.
>> Okay, let's speak a little bit about the
first inifada, the second inifada, the
suicide bombings uh and all that.
>> Yeah. Well, all of this is just more of
the giad. when they talk about inifada
you know it's a it's a term of
tremendous significance it means an
uprising or shaking off the oppressor
all these things and people especially
Marxists love that kind of talk you know
and they love to style themselves as the
oppressor fighting against the I mean it
appeals to their heroic self-image but
really the inifadas are just more
intensified episodes of jihad it's all
jihad with the ultimate goal of
eradicating Israel. Suicide bombings
take place because the Quran promises
paradise to those who kill and are
killed for Allah. Now, this is very
important because that's the only
promise of paradise in the Quran. See,
in Islam, your good deeds are on one
scale and your bad deeds are on another.
And if your good deeds outweigh your bad
deeds, you go to paradise. If your bad
deeds outweigh your good deeds, you go
to hell. Now, how many good deeds and
bad deeds have you committed? And how
much does each one weigh? You don't
know, right? I don't know. And so,
imagine if you're a believing Muslim and
you really think that this is happening.
You're torment. You could be tormented
by the fear of hell, which is very, very
lavishly described in the Quran. You
know, Allah is going to burn off your
skin and then issue you and you skin so
he can burn that one off and pour molts
and lead down your throat and all these
terrible things and forever. It never
ends. So how do you get out of hell? How
do you ensure that you don't go to hell?
Well, one way is to kill and be killed
for Allah. That's the promise of
paradise in chapter 9 verse 111. And so
as the only promise of paradise in the
Quran, it makes suicide attacks
extremely attractive. Also, there's the
fact that heaven place in the Quran is a
big bordello full of babes and you just
have sex for all eternity. So, there was
a kid
about 13 years old, 14, and this was a
few years ago, long before October 7th,
but he was stopped at a checkpoint in
Israel, and he had a bomb strapped on.
And the IDF sent out their automated
bomb disarm, which is quite a machine
really, so nobody ends up getting blown
up. You know, they don't have to go and
untie the bomb from the kid and risk
having it detonate. They send this
little automated thing out and it
diffuses the bomb and takes it off. So,
he's standing there. He's standing there
in his underwear because they it's
they've taken off all his clothes and
they're taking off the bomb with the
machine and he calls out to the IDF
soldiers, "How am I going to get to
paradise now and meet the virgins?" He
takes this very seriously and it's a
it's a great inducement.
>> Wow. Okay, let's let's skip to October
7th. you know, the the media's double
standard, showing Israel as an
aggressor, Hamas winning the information
war and sympathy from the West and and
all that.
>> It seems like it was a concerted effort
that was planned long before October
7th, that when October 7th took place,
immediately there was a PR machine,
propaganda machine that was going to
roll into action to demonize the
Israelis. And I saw this, you know, in
real time as it was unfolding, for
example, on the on the among American
conservatives or on the right in
America, always very pro-Israel. And
then suddenly it turned and of course we
all know about Tucker Carlson and
Candace Owens and so on. But I saw a
much less well-known figure, a man named
Elijah Schaefer who was working with, he
might still be for all I know, a group
called Gateway Pundit. and he had he had
a very large following on Twitter, you
know, 500,000 people, 700,000 people,
something like that. And I saw on
October 8th,
2023, that he said what Hamas did
yesterday was terrible, and what Israel
is doing today is terrible. I thought
Israel isn't doing anything today. If
you recall, Israel did not go into Gaza
for several weeks after October 7th. And
Israel wasn't doing a thing on October
8th except reeling from the horror of
what had happened. But he was already
primed and ready with his Israel is
committing genocide. You know, by
November, only a month after the October
7th attack, the incoming mayor of New
York, Zoran Mandani, was accusing Israel
of genocide. And I think, you know, you
don't have this kind of thing. Those
those two examples are just two of many
without there being some pre-planning
that they knew already they were going
to whatever Israel did, they were going
to pounce on it and try to portray it in
the worst possible light and of course
wildly exaggerate and lie about it as
well. So yeah.
>> So why do you think that the Western
elites, the universities, media, they
all sympathize with these terror groups?
Hamas filmed themselves doing what they
did on October 7th and it's still as if
that doesn't exist.
>> Well, a lot of it is the Marxist slant
of America's colleges and universities.
So, they see the world in terms of the
oppressor and the oppressed. And when
you enter that world, it's like a
funhouse mirror. You know, everything
might make sense within it, but it
doesn't make any sense with reference to
the outside. And it's the same kind of
thing in the universities. If you are an
oppressed person, then you can do
whatever you want and they will make
excuses for you. Now, you may not really
be an oppressed person. You just may
have the claim, but if they buy your
claim, they'll run interference for you.
So, the universities have been under the
control of Marxists for decades. I mean,
when I was in college in the 80s, my
professors were all Marxists,
and it's only been it's only gotten
worse since then. And so
now you have these professors who are
Marxists and they teach their their
their students that the Palestinians are
oppressed people and that the the
Israelis are white colonialists. And
then if something is done, if some jihad
attack happens, they say, "You see, the
oppressor is so oppressive that he drove
the oppressed to do this. that they and
they had it coming because of all the
terrible things that they've done and
there were talking points to this
effect. I saw several care officials,
Council on American Islamic Relations,
saying Israel is an occupying power, so
it has no right to defend itself and
Hamas, Gaza is occupied, which of course
it isn't really or it hasn't been since
2005, but anyway, Gaza is occupied and
therefore whatever the Gazins do to
relieve their plight is justified. And
this kind of thing went out all over.
Can you speak a little bit about the
United Nations and the bias that they
have and they always had against Israel
and is there anything that could be
done?
>> The United Nations is made up of two
major groups, communists and Muslims
just like the left Islamic alliance
everywhere. You have communists who hate
Israel because they want to establish an
[snorts] internationalist collective, a
massive multinational state that is
socialist and doesn't have borders
because it encompasses everywhere. And
they want to destroy the United States
because it's the foremost nation state.
And if you're waring against the very
idea of the nation state, you take out
the biggest one, the most important one,
and then the others fall into line. And
also if you want to destroy the nation
state and establish an international
mega state, you also hate the one group
of people who've never assimilated into
the larger collective throughout
history. But they have always resisted
and kept to their own traditions, their
own customs, their own community. And
they weren't attacking the outer
community, but they just wouldn't join
it. So the international left, although
many Jews of course are leftists, I
would respectfully suggest they have not
thought this through. The international
left is essentially anti-Israel and
anti-Jewish. Because even Karl Marx
wrote about the necessity for the Jews
to stop being Jews, to melt into the
larger community as part of the
collective. Communism is a collectivist
thing. So you got them on the one hand
and on the other you have the
organization of Islamic cooperation. Now
the Soviet block used to be the largest
voting block at the United Nations. The
Soviet Union of course fell. That was
not the end of communism. As I was just
saying there plenty of communists still
at the UN. But also the largest voting
block today is the organization of
Islamic cooperation. 56 Muslim
governments plus the Palestinians. and
they hate Israel, of course, because of
all the Islamic things that I've been
explaining. So, the two of them work
together in the United Nations to
demonize Israel. And it's really kind of
ridiculous. There's a standing item on
the Security Council agenda, item seven.
Every time they meet, they talk about
Israeli crimes, item seven on the
agenda. No other country gets that kind
of treatment. And so you look around the
world, you look at at North Korea, at
Iran, human rights abusers all around
the world and they pick on Israel and
that's because of the communists and the
OIC.
>> Could you speak a little bit? We spoke
about the Muslim Brotherhood, but there
are Arab countries that ban the Muslim
Brotherhood, but in the West, I mean in
the United States, for example, they're
still flourishing. So can you speak a
little bit on that? Well, the Muslim
Brotherhood there always attempts to ban
it in the United States or get it
designated a terrorist group in the
United States and they always fail
because Muslim Brotherhood infiltration
has already advanced to the point that
they can stop any such initiative and
they do. So, uh once again we see talk
about getting the Muslim Brotherhood
designated a terror group and once again
it ain't going to work. Unfortunately,
however, it is true the Muslim
Brotherhood is dedicated, according to a
captured internal document, to
eliminating and destroying Western
civilization from within and sabotaging
its miserable house. And they're doing
that very well. But yeah, there are
countries in the Middle East that have
banned the Muslim Brotherhood, notably
Egypt, the country of its birth, because
they don't want to be Sharia states.
Egypt is not a Sharia state. Neither is
Jordan or some of the other places where
the Brotherhood's activities are
restricted. They don't want the
Brotherhood around because it's a direct
challenge to their own authority.
>> Could you speak a little bit also about
Qatar and how they're playing the double
game being the mediators with Hamas and
then being friends with the with the
United States? What what do you have to
say about that?
>> A strange case of short-sightedness on
the part of Trump. nine or ten years ago
he was very clear cutter is a
international sponsor of terrorism
should not be tolerated and now we're
big pals and they're going to give him
an airplane and they're going to be
negotiating with everybody
it's crazy because Qatar is the chief
sponsor of the Muslim Brotherhood and
the Muslim Brotherhood is Hamas they had
the Hamas leaders there you've seen the
video footage of them watching October
7th attacks and then getting down and
praising a law for killing Israelis. And
these people are are, you know, this is
still the same people in charge of
Qatar. They didn't expel them. They
didn't say, "Oh, horrors. We had a
change of heart. We shouldn't have had
these Hamas guys here." They haven't
said a word. Except Obama. Trump forced
Netanyahu to call and apologize for
bombing the Hamas leaders in in Qatar.
Well, does Trump has Trump forgotten
that they're a chief sponsor of
terrorism? Does he really think they're
nice guys now? It's incredible
short-sightedness and it's only going to
come back to bite us.
>> Is it possible to defeat Hamas? What
does that mean ideologically and
militarily?
>> It is possible to defeat Hamas and
destroy it as an organization. Hamas
started in 1987 and it could have a
death date as well. That's not to say
that the jihad will end. The jihad will
never end. As long as there are
believers in Allah and Islam and the
Quran, there will be the jihad. However,
that doesn't mean that it will always
have this organization or be able to
fight at this kind level of strength.
And you look back a hundred years ago,
that was the time of the founding of
secular Turkey and there was secular
movements elsewhere as well. Iran
followed Turkey under Raash Sha followed
Turkey and created a westernstyle
secular society that lasted until 1979
when the Islamic Republic overthrew it.
in uh the 1950s, Gaml Abdul Nasser, the
president of Egypt. You can see the
video on YouTube. He is talking to an
audience and he says, "The Muslim
Brotherhood says all the women should
wear hijab." And the audience laughs and
he says, "And I told them you make them
wear it." And the audience laughs even
harder. And they all are agreed there in
Egypt in the late 50s that it's absurd
that Egyptian women are never going to
wear hijab. Now you go to Egypt, they
all wear hijab. Now the point is that
the jihad was not gone when the Egyptian
women were not wearing the hijab and
Turkey and Iran were secular. The jihad
was still there, but the jihadis were
far less powerful and did not have the
cultural ascendancy that they do now. So
what we need to do is be strong
militarily as culturally as well as
militarily. They understand that you
don't, as a matter of fact, it's Islamic
law, you don't wage jihad against an
enemy that has more than twice your
strength and against whom you have no
chance of winning. So if we had
projected strength, they would not be
fighting. If we had projected strength,
there would be more adaturks saying we
should be like them and give up this
Islam that's failed. But we have not
projected strength. We've projected
weakness. And so we have more jihad. If
we had destroyed Hamas, many people
would say maybe Allah does not reward
piety in the way that we expected after
all. Maybe we should give this up. But
since we did not destroy Hamas, Hamas is
saying, look, we won because we
survived. And so we will press on to
final victory. There you go. It's I if
if we had crushed Hamas, there would be
a lot less jihad. Not no jihad, but a
lot less. Do you think that there are
signs of hope for for Israel to I I know
they cannot fully crush this threat, but
um what do you think the future looks
like? Well, they there I don't think
that it's a bad thing for them to be
pursuing these pragmatic accords, the
Abraham Accords, that are not based on
Islam. They need to understand that
there are hardliners in every one of the
Abraham Accords countries who think that
they're wrong, that they shouldn't make
an agreement with the Jews because of
what the Quran says and so on. And
really, they only exist because Iran is
a threat. And the if the Islamic
Republic falls, the Abraham Accords will
probably fall as well. The nevertheless,
the more they can establish working
arrangements with those countries, the
better off that they are. And that at
least is something. It's not going to
solve all the problems, but it can at
least make life a little bit less
immediately threatening for the
Israelis.
>> Do you think that that other countries
like Saudi Arabia and and others could
um join this U Abrahamic courts?
>> Well, Saudi Arabia has made a very clear
condition that they will not join unless
a Palestinian state is established and
that Israel retreat to the 1967 borders,
which of course Aban called the Ashvitz
borders. They are very difficult to
defend. It's really miraculous that
Israel survived for 18 years with those
borders when there was only it's only 9
miles from the sea to the border
according to those borders at some
points. And that's you know you with
modern warfare that's hardly anything.
And so it would be very foolish if the
Israelis were to agree to that. It's
remotely possible that Trump might
pressure them to do so. We'll see. He's
very erratic. But uh if that's the
condition for the Saudi normalization,
Israel can live without the Saudi
normalization.
>> Okay. I want to ask you a last question.
There's a lot of talk about, you know,
America first. We don't need Israel and
all that. Um and obviously we you
mentioned Tucker Carlson. Can you speak
about why America does need Israel and
what America gains from Israel? There's
a tremendous amount of cooperation that
I think people don't know about between
America and Israel in matters of
military uh hardware and material and
also intelligence. The Israelis have
been extremely generous in sharing
various amount kinds of information with
the American government. It's not a
one-way alliance in the slightest
degree. Also, just in a general sense,
America first does not mean and should
not mean America alone in the sense of
America having no allies. Israel faces a
common foe that we face as well. People
don't know because they don't study the
area. But Hamas and Hisbala and Iran,
they have the same ideology 100% as
those who struck the United States on
911 and who still want to see the United
States brought down. And so, why
shouldn't we ally with with Israel? is
the choice then to ally with states that
are full of people who hold to the same
ideology that wants to destroy us. I
don't see that as a better alternative.
>> Where can people find find you, find
more about you, purchase one of your
books, anything you want to promote?
>> I'm uh at jihadwatch.org.
That's jihadwatch.org.
Updated many times daily with news about
jihad activity, commentary to help you
understand it. And that's very important
cuz most everybody lies about what it's
all about or just doesn't know. But
anyway, that's that. Jihadwatch RS on
Twitter X and the books are at Amazon,
Barnes & Noble, wherever fine books are
sold. Don't go with the if you see the
sign says we only sell lousy books,
don't go in there. But if you see a
bookstore says fine books sold here,
mine will be in there. If you see a
bookstore and uh anyway, yeah, the books
are at Amazon. I have a book, The
Palestinian Delusion, about the Middle
East peace process and why it always
fails. And also, anti-semitism history
and myth, which is uh a response to
really the anti-semitism we've seen
since October 7. Many other books, the
history of jihad. I have a new book out
actually called Inifat on the Hudson,
the selling of Zukran Mamani about the
new mayor of New York.
>> Okay. Thank you very much.